night we start with march madness how
fun is this tournament been
wild upsets but now the contenders are
separating themselves from the
pretenders
and the biggest contender just three
wins away from doing something that
hasn't been done
in years the zags are looking to become
the first team since 1976 to go the
distance
and win the title with a perfect season
well look at that list right there
rutgers was also a team in 76 to beat
they lost in the final four same with
unlv which probably
had the most talented team but also
losing in the final four to arizona but
the zags they are for real
they're the number one seed heading into
the tournament boy they've shown it all
they have not slowed down
and look at this another win today the
number one seeded bulldogs advanced to
the elite eight
of the men's tournament with an 83-65
beat down in number five seed creighton
drew timmy scored a team-high 22 points
for the zags
they again play on tuesday the last five
unbeatens to enter the tournament since
that hoosiers team have fallen short of
winning the title
the best attribute that these guys has
have is just
how much they love each other and the
way they play together
and they just they really really enjoy
passing and they know how to pass
they know how to play together and
that's definitely our strength